Україну підтримують
в усіх куточках світу.
[скандують]
Україна! Україна!
Іноземці та українська діаспора
на різних континентах.
— Слава Україні!
— Героям слава!
Кожен українець будь-де в світі
повинен хоча б якусь малу крихту
додати до нашої перемоги.
Автівки, медичне обладнання,
квадрокоптери.
Все це люди закуповують
власними силами,
і відправляють прямо на передову.
Досить складно сидіти, склавши руки,
і, в принципі, памʼятати,
шо в тебе є якесь нормальне життя,
коли вся Україна у вогні.
Волонтери організовують
прихистки для тих,
хто через
повномасштабну війну з Росією
тимчасово покинув свій дім
чи втратив його.
Роблять усе, щоб українці почувалися
в безпеці і як удома.
Хіба цей народ можна побороти?
Цей народ непереможний.
Численні мітинги, марші миру.
Весь цивілізований світ скандує
слова підтримки Україні
у боротьбі з російськими окупантами.
Земна куля така
маленька і кругленька,
а існування діаспори є
свого роду супер сила.
Це історія українців,
які відстоюють свою незалежність
і самобутність, де б не були.
Те життя, як було до 24 лютого,
його просто вже немає.
Це був перший день
нашого нового життя.
Якщо ми станемо байдужими,
то що ми скажемо своїм дітям?
Це історія волонтерів
із різних куточків світу,
які працюють заради одного —
перемоги України.
[Путін = Гітлер]
[Україна вільна]
[Путін вбивця]
Добре відомі гасла
на іншому континенті.
Це мітинг у Мексиці
на підтримку України.
З перших днів війни
мирні акції організовує
потужна українська громада
в Мехіко.
Хоч українцям тут, за океаном,
важко було повірити в
нову реальність їхньої Батьківщини.
Була десь друга ночі
в Україні 24 лютого,
а в Мексиці було 23 лютого,
шоста вечора.
Пам'ятаю, що я подумала:
«Окей, я відкрию Flightradar,
і подивлюся
чи є взагалі літаки в небі»
Літаків не було ні у Львові,
ні в Одесі, ні в Києві, ні в Харкові.
Взагалі жоден літак
не пролітав над Україною.
Протести в Мехіко розпочалися ще
до повномасштабного вторгнення.
Активісти виходили на вулиці,
закликаючи до миру в світі.
До початку війни 20 лютого
українська громада ходила на протести:
на мирний протест,
на щасливий протест,
про те, що російська армія
має піти з кордонів.
Але коли ми зустрілися 24 лютого,
це були інші люди.
За ці чотири дні ми усі
змінилися кардинально.
Я побачила дівчат, в яких вже не було щік,
побачила заплаканих чоловіків.
Ми зібралися біля
російського посольства.
Я там теж почала теж знімати кадри.
Я зрозуміла, що оці кадри,
які я зняла 20 лютого,
вже нікому не потрібні.
Українці просто не можуть вийти
з плакатом і сказати: «Мир всім».
Українці можуть тільки вийти з плакатом
і сказати: «Перемога Україні»,
що ми, власне, і робили.
Щоб бути почутими —
щоразу влаштовували нові перформанси.
Із початком війни змінилися і гасла.
Мітингувальники більше
не просять миру,
а закликають підтримати Україну
в боротьбі з окупантом.
Щонеділі в Мехіко був мітинг,
який був не просто мітингом,
а це був перформанс.
Наприклад, одного разу ми вийшли
як дівчата в білих сукнях,
заляпаних кров'ю,
як символ того, що українські жінки
можуть недочекатися чоловіків з фронту.
Іншого дня був мітинг,
коли мексиканський композитор
запросив скрипальку,
і вона грала його музику про Україну.
На кожен мітинг приходило
дуже багато медіа,
ми були на шпальтах місцевих газет,
про нас знімали репортажі.
Далі ми зрозуміли,
що одними протестами дуже важко
чогось досягти.
Ми почали збирати
гуманітарну допомогу.
Але мексиканська влада
нам не дозволила
збирати важке озброєння,
або бронежилети чи каски.
Тому єдине, що ми могли зібрати,
це ліки та продукти харчування.
Завдяки цим протестам
української діаспори,
підтримувати Україну почало
все більше місцевих.
Мексиканці роблять благодійні внески
і самі виходять на мітинги й акції.
Я запитала в одного хлопця на мітингу,
теж мексиканця:
«Слухай, а яке у тебе
відношення до Путіна?»
Він каже: «Це так цікаво,
бо зараз я його звісно ненавиджу,
але п'ять років тому, до того,
як я зустрів свою українську дружину,
я завжди думав, що Росія —
це така велика країна,
з гарною економікою,
і Путін — це такий великий лідер,
який тримає цю країну.
Коли я познайомився з моєю дружиною,
і вона мені розповіла про війну,
про голодомори, про те, що Росія
хоче повернутися в Радянський Союз,
про репресії, про Майдани...
Я зрозумів,
що це ніякий не великий лідер,
а це просто кривавий диктатор».
І він змінив своє ставлення до Путіна.
Розказати світові правду про
кривавого російського диктатора
та залучити якнайбільше людей
до боротьби з ним і його режимом.
Ось те, заради чого люди організовували
всі ці мирні мітинги,
акції та перформанси.
І правда, сказана вголос,
дійсно змінювала ставлення
мексиканців до війни в Україні.
Наша ціль як українців в Мексиці
була — саме показати
Латинській Америці та Америці,
про те, що відбувається в Україні.
Те, що Україна — це незалежна країна.
І Росія — це агресор.
Героям слава!
Слава Нації!
Смерть ворогам!
Україна понад усе!
А ці гасла звучать вже
в сусідній нам Польщі.
Закривавлені іграшки,
унітази з фото Путіна
і його такими ж
кривавими соратниками.
Цей перформанс —
реакція на цинічне мародерство
російських окупантів в Україні.
Путін — х*йло!
Щоб світ не забував,
треба створювати нафтопроводи.
Треба робити так,
щоб Україна з'являлася в інфопросторі.
Остання статистика показує, що
в світових ЗМІ згадки
про війну в Україні
з'являються у 22 рази рідше,
ніж це було на початку березня.
Тобто світ починає вже втомлюватися
від цієї теми,
і він не хоче так часто про війну чути.
А доки війна в нас є,
це наше завдання зробити так,
щоб вони про неї чули.
[Україна без Путіна]
Тут активні протести тривають і нині.
Їх організовують представники
української діаспори.
24 лютого було жахливим,
мабуть, як і у всіх українців.
Я спала...
І у мене почав о четвертій чи п'ятій ранку
за польським часом дзвонити телефон.
А я з малою сплю,
думаю, зараз дитину розбудять.
І тут дзвонить мама.
І я розумію, що мама час
точно не переплутала б,
і це час, в який
мама не дзвонить ніколи.
Я беру слухавку спросоння,
вона мені каже: «Алло, почалась війна».
А в нас була запланована акція
до річниці окупації Криму —
до речі, це як раз ті самі дати —
під посольством Росії.
Я телефоную в поліцію з самого ранку
і кажу, що акція буде, але тема зовсім інша.
І ми скликаємо всіх через Facebook
і робимо протест, акцію проти війни.
І все, як почалась ця перша акція,
далі у мене все в тумані.
Після того це були десятки акцій
кожного дня.
Варшава ходором ходила.
Починаючи акціями під
російським посольством проти війни,
Закінчуючи акціями в центрі Варшави
за солідарність з Україною.
Збирання гуманітарної допомоги
на усіх цих акціях,
бо ми прямо на акції привозили автобуси,
просили людей, щоб вони
приносили медикаменти,
в інтернеті вивішували список
що саме треба купити.
Люди бігали по всій Варшаві,
скуповували аптеки,
приносили нам до машин,
і машини прямо з акцій їхали в Україну.
Прямо з мітингів автівки
з гуманітарною допомогою
їхали до
польсько-українського кордону.
І в той самий час польський кордон
перетинали фури з вантажем
для країни-агресорки.
І ми зрозуміли, що переважно все,
що з Європи,
в Росію зараз потрапляє
цими фурами.
Бо море закрите, небо закрите,
лишаються лише вантажівки.
І ми вирішили їхати
розібратись — що там.
Я не пам'ятаю,
нас було три машини, чи п'ять.
Словом, кілька машин з Варшави.
Ми зібралися в машини, щоб раптом,
якщо там буде страшно,
чи нас почнуть бити,
щоб ми хоча б знали, хто з ким приїхав,
і були якісь свідки.
І щоб нас там ніхто не вбив.
І ми поїхали дивитись що там.
Почали просто розпитувати водіїв.
Вони нам порозповідали,
чому вони там стоять.
І все: ми зрозуміли,
що треба блокувати.
Що це — жах. Що вони везуть
у Росію все підряд.
Що майже все, що стояло там в черзі,
їде саме в Росію, не в Білорусь,
не в Казахстан.
Я підійшла до поліції і сказала,
що ми оголошуємо
спонтанну і безстрокову акцію.
Зареєструвала її прямо там.
Вийшла перед фурою і стала.
І все, так перша фура зупинилась.
Фура мала вибір:
або їхати на людей або стояти.
Вона стояла тільки тому,
що перед нею стояли люди.
Вони не могли на нас поїхати.
Вони зупинились і все, це тому,
що ми стали під колеса.
Лише тому вони не поїхали.
А потім почалась величезна черга.
З'їхалась уся поліція,
з'їхались прикордонники.
Всі почали з нами торгуватися,
просити, щоб ми зійшли,
пропускали хоча б п'ять фур на годину.
Словом, служби почали
виконувати свою роботу, а ми свою.
Ці протести безперервно
тривали майже місяць.
Непохитність українських активістів
стала приводом
для введення нових санкцій
ЄС проти Росії.
Так не працює — коли лише я.
Це працює лише коли всі разом.
Якби я одна приїхала і стала
на кордоні перед фурою,
я не думаю що щось би змінилось.
Правда?
І того більше, я не думаю що
Європейський Союз прийняв би
в п'ятому пакеті санкцій, пункт,
якби якась одна незрозуміла дівчина
стояла перед фурами.
Ні, це зробили ми.
Завдяки людям, які кинули все і
приїхали туди, на кордон.
Завдяки людям,
які приходять на наші акції.
які малюють плакати,
приходять їх потримати, дівчатам,
які шиють прапори.
Завдяки тисячам людей
нашу ініціативу помітили.
Ось чому такі ініціативи
мають тривати.
Треба щоб світ, який поки що
спостерігає за війною із новин,
допоміг зупинити
кривавого російського диктатора.
Зараз говорити
про Україну дуже важливо.
І будь-яка нагода говорити про Україну,
вона має бути використана,
ними не можна нехтувати.
Бучу та Ірпінь просто всі побачили,
зараз таких місць — пів України.
Але їх ніхто не бачить.
Тому нам треба не зупинятись.
Іноземні журналісти,
якими вони не були класними,
рано чи пізно втомляться від війни.
А нам не можна втомлюватись.
Нам треба колихати
цей інфопростір
і робити так, щоб він постійно
був забитий Україною.
[чоловік співає «Ой у лузі червона калина»,
діти підспівують]
Чеська галерея «Аву».
Зазвичай тут відбуваються виставки
сучасних художників.
Нині цей простір —
для українських дітей.
Тут можна поспівати українських пісень
і повчитися чогось нового.
Майстер-класи для дітей,
які через війну втратили дім,
проводить українська художниця.
Чеське мистецьке середовище
ставиться дуже тепло до українців,
і всі намагаються допомогти і
провести свої майстер-класи.
Спеціально для українських дітей.
Олена Загребіна жила в Чернігові.
Вона мисткиня і викладачка.
Олена пережила блокаду міста.
Опинившись в безпеці,
вирішила допомагати тим,
що у неї виходить якнайкраще.
До війни вона теж проводила
майстер-класи для дітей.
А зараз для Олени — це ще й можливість
підтримати один одного після пережитого.
Дітки з різних міст,
багато дітей з Києва, з Пущі-Водиці.
Є діти з Харкова,
є діти з невеличких поселень.
У всіх різна історія,
як вони потрапили за кордон.
Для мене це був експеримент —
як з ними розмовляти про те, що відбулось.
Перше, що я робила — це налаштовувала
їх на мирні якісь такі теми.
Головною темою я вирішила зробити
в цих майстер-класах саме тему пташок.
І ми варіювали які саме: це пташка об'ємна,
це пташка намальована.
Якась історія, пов'язана з пташками.
Щоб таким чином завершити і
зробити цей майстер-клас цільним.
І пташиний марш, який відбудеться,
це буде певне завершення цих занять,
які ми проводили.
Більшість українських дітей,
які евакуювалися сюди,
виїхали із зон активних бойових дій.
Багатьом доводилося ховатися
в підвалах від бомбардувань,
і навіть пережити
окупацію рідних сіл і містечок.
З початку війни до країн Євросоюзу
виїхало близько мільйона українських дітей.
Більш ніж половина з них
зараз у сусідній Польщі.
Саме Польща прийняла найбільшу
кількість українських біженців.
Прийняла гостинно, забезпечивши
комфортні умови для життя
та створивши чимало
державних програм підтримки українців.
Поруч зі щиросердними поляками,
допомагають своїм і українці,
які вже освоїлись тут.
Яна Опарій — одна з тих,
хто переїхала у Польщу
задовго до
повномасштабного вторгнення.
З 24 лютого цьогоріч моє життя,
як і в більшості українців,
повністю перевернулося,
і більшу частину вільного часу
я присвячую допомозі біженцям тут,
у Польщі, і у Варшаві зокрема.
Яна, як і багато представників
місцевої української діаспори,
волонтерила в штабі
для українських біженців у Варшаві.
Перші два тижні це просто жах був.
Я кидалася з одного місця в інше,
щоб допомогти якось.
Постійно доводилось перевіряти новини,
бо я дуже хвилювалася за родину,
яка була в Сумах.
Більш-менш свій план дій
якось сформувати чітко я змогла
десь аж під кінець березня.
Я чітко розуміла:
так, я можу волонтерити
з самого ранку і ввечері або вночі,
бо якусь частину часу я працюю.
Поки що я займаюся тим,
що допомагаю біженцям
з реєстрацією документів.
Дуже багато поляків долучилися
до допомоги з документами,
у реєстрації, пошуці роботи.
Ми будемо робити такий проєкт,
щоб українці знали,
де можуть себе знайти.
Зʼявився сайт, до речі,
warszawaukraina.pl —
там є вся інформація наразі,
де чим можна допомогти українцям.
Там ночівля, їжа, одяг, психологічна
і юридична допомога —
це все є на одному сайті.
І пізніше будемо робити такі проєкти
більш освітні для українців,
щоб вони трошки чогось навчилися.
Тобто якісь мінімальні речі —
на перший час хоча б щось,
що може бути корисним.
Інші наші країни-сусіди хоч
і не висловлюють
такої проактивної підтримки,
але приймають тих,
хто постраждав внаслідок війни.
Йдеться про Угорщину,
скандально відому
блокуванням санкцій проти Росії.
Костянтин — один із тих,
кому українські біженці в Угорщині
завдячують своїм прихистком.
Він з однодумцями ініціював
волонтерський штаб.
Так українська діаспора
почала підтримувати людей
зі своєї батьківщини.
Пам'ятаю ранок 24 лютого.
Я прокидаюся.
Зазвичай у мене телефон
на авіарежимі,
виключаю авіарежим і починають
бомбити мене ці всі повідомлення.
Я спочатку думав,
що це якийсь першоквітневий жарт.
Потім відкриваю я Telegram,
ці всі групи,
і бачу відео як бомби летять
навіть в Івано-Франківськ.
У той момент я відчув,
що у мене серце десь в п'ятках,
мене залив холодний піт.
Це було важко емоційно перенести.
Я почав дзвонити рідним.
Як у них справи? Що вони роблять?
Всюди була величезна паніка.
Це вияснилось, що з четвертої ранку
почалися бомбардування
і в Україні вже введений воєнний стан.
Напевно, це був найважчий момент
у моєму житті.
Представництво
Української греко-католицької церкви
допомогло з приміщенням.
Завдяки цьому штаб для біженців з України
розташований у самому центрі Будапешта.
У перші два дні прийшов на роботу,
я відчував просто якусь пустоту,
я не міг працювати так, як мої колеги.
Вони є угорці, їх це настільки
не торкалося питання війни.
Я бачив як вони ходять повсякденно,
так само розмовляють на свої теми.
Мене турбувало це зсередини,
я не міг працювати,
і я вирішив піти у відпустку,
пізніше я навіть звільнився з роботи.
Женя у нас на рецепшені.
Привітайся Женя.
— Доброго дня!
Він приймає заявки
на соціальні пакети.
Сюди люди приходять,
пишуть списки — що їм потрібно.
От якраз у нас відбувається цей процес.
Можете спостерігати.
— Привіт, Ukraїner! Україна понад усе!
Тримайтесь. Ми з вами.
— Тут ми формуємо списки людей
з потребами, і далі наші водії
везуть уже на місце дислокації.
Так, тут у нас є невеличка кухня.
Ось тут волонтери
приходять харчуватися.
У нас є прекрасна Марина,
яка для них готує
ці всі гарячі/холодні харчі.
Зараз вона відпочиває,
слухає музику.
А так взагалі 12 годин
вона стоїть на ногах,
всім робить бутерброди.
Давай пять!
І ми зустрічались на вокзалі,
пробували допомагати людям,
які приїжджають,
які в перші дні тікали від війни.
Був великий наплив.
Потім у нас організувався штаб,
в якому ми зараз перебуваємо.
Тут допомагають не тільки біженцям.
Волонтери збирають і відправляють
вантажі гуманітарки в Україну,
адресно допомагають підрозділам
Збройних Сил України.
Люди буквально живуть можливістю
зробити хоч щось заради перемоги України.
По-іншому я не міг вчинити,
я мусив допомагати.
Тому що я себе відчуваю в безпеці,
але я розумів,
що люди потребують моєї допомоги,
хоча б такої,
яку я можу надати з-за кордону.
Цей волонтерський штаб — у Болгарії.
Він теж розташований у столиці,
і ним так само опікуються
представники української діаспори.
Тут біженцям з України
допомагають із найнеобхіднішим.
Коли мені кажуть, що є хороші росіяни,
я кажу: «Не зараз!».
Інколи мені знайомі кажуть,
що я занадто категорична в своїх поглядах.
Я не розумію і
не хочу поки що розуміти.
Я змінилася, скажу чесно,
ще у 2014 році.
Треба було якийсь вік пережити.
У 2014 році, коли я побачила як стріляють,
за що можна вбивати,
за те, що ти розмовляєш
своєю рідною мовою,
за те, що ти любиш свою рідну землю,
за те, що ти знаєш, чого ти помираєш.
Я зрозуміла, що український народ
відрізняється від російського народу
тим, що він може померти
за свою свободу.
Тетяна Тошева —
вчителька української мови.
Вона вже 12 років живе в Болгарії.
Чоловік зранку підійшов до мене і каже:
«Таня, росіяни вторглися на нашу територію».
Він сам болгарин, але так каже:
«Вторглися на нашу територію».
Я вам скажу, та я й зараз не вірю в це,
дивлячись на цю трагедію,
яку принесла війна,
я не вірю й дотепер, я не можу.
Мій розум не може це збагнути,
моя душа не може збагнути,
мій розум не може збагнути.
Мені здається,
що я в якомусь кіно знімаюся чи живу.
Щось треба робити.
Треба якось допомагати іншим.
Я зрозуміла, що вже пішли біженці
з України в Болгарію.
Я просто прийшла в фонд,
знайшла фонд «Мати Україна».
Зараз ми з вами знаходимось
в центрі допомоги біженцям,
я зараз тут працюю з початку війни.
Ми допомагаємо біженцям,
допомагаємо їжею, речами,
всім самим необхідним.
Коли людина опиняється в такому стані,
коли вона біжить тільки з документами,
втікає від війни.
Все що даємо: постіль,
туалетний папір, ліки.
Допомагаємо, підтримуємо морально,
даємо якісь консультації,
куди піти, до кого звернутись,
де й кому зателефонувати.
Основне, що хочу сказати:
все, що тут є, приносять звичайні люди.
Ми не займаємось,
як наші керівники, грошима,
вони там закупляють
якісь продукти, чи ліки,
чи комусь дають біженцям.
Ми безпосередньо залежні від людей,
болгар, які несуть нам все це.
І їжу, і посуд, і речі,
і шампунь, і все [інше].
Тому, якщо ви бачите, що у всіх все є,
значить, хороших, розуміючих людей більше.
Ми є, ми нація,
ми такі і ми будемо існувати.
«Народ мій є,
народ мій завжди буде!»
Все, крапка.
Ця хвиля еміграції найпотужніша
з часів Другої світової війни.
Росія хотіла створити
гуманітарну катастрофу в Європі,
та це їй не вдалося.
В сотнях міст Європи українцям
допомагають і приймають як своїх.
Усі ці ініціативи — це протистояння
європейської спільноти країні-агресорці.
Адже це війна Росії не тільки з Україною,
а й з усім європейським світом.
В’єтнам, Південно-східна Азія.
У мирні часи з цією державою
Україна співпрацювала,
зокрема в освітніх проєктах.
Повномасштабна війна тільки
посилила цю взаємодію.
І в цьому велика заслуга українців,
які вибудовують культурні зв'язки
між Україною і В'єтнамом.
Я живу в столиці В'єтнаму,
в місті Ханой.
Після 24-го, коли все сталося,
я зрозуміла, що ми і іноземці,
які живуть за кордоном,
також маємо допомагати Україні.
Я хотіла, щоб дуже багато людей
у Вʼєтнамі і в світі
знали про ситуацію в Україні
і допомагали нам.
Саме тому Аліна Липовенко
почала організовувати культурні заходи.
З пошуком українців для організації
івентів проблеми не було.
У Вʼєтнамі є дуже гарна
українська спільнота.
Ми знаємо один одного,
і коли в нас є якісь проблема або ідеї,
ми завжди спілкуємось
і допомагаємо один одному.
Перший захід пройшов на
території українського посольства
в місті Ханой.
До нас прийшло близько тисячі людей,
які відвідали цей захід,
купили наші сувеніри, скуштували їжу,
і підтримали Україну, як тільки можна.
Ми зібрали близько 50 000 доларів
з цього заходу,
і всі ці гроші
були відправлені в Україну.
Культурні зв’язки — це те,
що допомагає націям порозумітися.
Як ви знаєте у Вʼєтнамі вони
[керівництво держави]
дотримуються нейтральної позиції.
І тому — дуже багато людей
насправді нас підтримує —
але вони не можуть
офіційно про це сказати,
тому що це може повипливати
на їх кар'єру.
Хоча на наші заходи прийшло
дуже багато людей,
вони нас підтримали і грошима,
і морально.
Вони дуже гарно ставляться до України:
дуже багато в'єтнамців було в Україні,
вони були там народжені,
або вони працювали, або навчалися.
Тому вони знають, що таке Україна,
і вони знають,
чого вони прийшли її підтримувати.
Я вважаю, що наразі це має
дуже велике значення,
тому що ми показуємо іншим країнам,
які ми, на що ми спроможні,
чому ми відстоюємо свою країну.
Тобто таким чином ми показуємо,
чому українці мають бути вільні.
У Великій Британії, яка є одним із
наших головних союзників,
культурні заходи на підтримку України
теж проходять регулярно.
Влаштовують різні виставки,
ярмарки, аукціони.
Я родом з України,
але останні сім років
проживаю у місті Манчестер.
З початком війни
я зайнялася волонтерством,
і працюю і роблю все для того,
щоб допомоги Україні.
Оксана Непийвода волонтерить
в українському соціальному
центрі «Дніпро» у Манчестері.
Сьогодні у нас в українському
соціальному центрі «Дніпро»
відбувається благодійна ярмарка,
де ми продаємо різноманітні вироби.
Якісь із них були зроблені
самими волонтерами.
Багато чого нам
допомагають волонтери і люди.
Просто надають безплатно.
Ці брошки — це є витвір мистецтва
української майстрині.
Це, наприклад, ми самі —
дівчата зв'язали, зробили.
Багато що —  малюємо картини.
І всі зібрані кошти
ми плануємо перевести
або закупити медичне обладнання
для України.
Звичний галас
мільйонного Нью-Йорка.
Але навіть, тут,
на іншому континенті,
люди відчувають потребу
підтримати Україну.
Прихильних до України американців
гуртує громадська організація
українців у США
під назвою Razom for Ukraine.
Життя змінилося і ще довго
не повернеться,
мені здається,
в наш нормальний темп.
Ми були на вечері в той час,
коли виступав Путін.
«Мною було прийнято рішення
про початок спеціальної військової операції».
Вже по своїх телефонах помітили,
що щось відбувається.
До того часу, як ми дійшли додому,
вже почалися бомбардування.
Це означало, що жоден з нас
не пішов спати, тому що ми відразу
зустрілися всією нашою
наглядовою радою Razom For Ukraine,
і почали обговорювати,
як на це реагуємо, що саме зараз ми робимо.
Razom for Ukraine ще з 2014 року допомагає
Україні протидіяти російській агресії.
Нині це один із основних
американських штабів підтримки України.
Я особисто дуже переживала,
знаючи історію України.
Побоюючись,
що люди не звертатимуть увагу.
Або, що люди попадуть
під дезінформацію,
або будуть без інформації.
Люди просто ділилися тим,
що вони мали:
навіть якщо то малі суми,
чи то хтось мав свій бізнес.
Як, наприклад, з піцерією.
Мене дуже вразило, що керівник
мав кілька ресторанів,
і він придумав спеціальну піцу
на підтримку України.
Безліч ініціатив —
від продажу американської піци
на підтримку України
до регулярних благодійних ярмарків.
Та ще більше людей просто
надсилали гроші,
щоб підтримати Україну
в боротьбі з окупантом.
Звідки приходять ці кошти?
Насправді з кожного куточку землі.
Тобто це особливо було помітно від початку,
коли нам почали писати люди:
були люди з Тайваню,
були люди з Гонконгу,
з Південної Кореї,
з Європи дуже багато.
Тобто люди знаходили якусь
українську організацію,
і це стало Razom For Ukraine
для багатьох людей у світі.
Особливо зворушливо було
отримати величезну підтримку
від простих людей з Америки.
За чотири місяці повномасштабної
війни фонд Razom for Ukraine
зібрав для України
57 мільйонів доларів.
У нас є такий архів, який ми колись
роздивимося дуже ретельно.
Це все, що приходило з чеками,
які ми отримали.
Діти писали,
цілі листи, які описують,
чому люди це роблять,
дякують нам.
Дівчата, які в нас відкривали ці
конверти і брали чеки, і це читали,
кажуть, що настільки
це інколи зворушливо,
що вони просто плакали
над цими листами.
І це дійсно те, що ми всі
українці в Америці відчули,
особливо в перші місяці — це величезну
підтримку американських людей.
Спрямувати кожен донат
на найнеобхідніше —
це для фонду Razom for Ukraine —
головний принцип роботи,
що став ще й викликом.
Ми не знали, що таке такмед,
це було нове слово для нас.
Це є спеціальне медицинське обладнання,
яке потрібне медикам на війні.
І от зараз я стою біля нашої
аптечки, яку ми формуємо
і для територіальної оборони, і для
ЗСУ в Україні, саме з такмедом.
І зараз ми всі знаємо, що таке
такмед, здається,
більшість людей в
Україні знають, що це.
Ми знаємо, що там мають
бути турнікети,
ми знаємо,
що вони мусять бути сертифіковані,
що не всі турнікети є добрими,
що треба закупати «CELOX»,
які є кровоспинними різними препаратами.
Тобто зараз кожен з нас вже
настільки обізнаний в тих речах,
тому що це — основне, що ми робимо.
Ми почали закупати такмед ще за
тиждень до 24 лютого.
І з 24 лютого, коли нам почали
надходити дуже багато донатів
від абсолютно різних людей,
ми змогли закупати цей такмед
у великих кількостях.
Більш як 40 тисяч таких аптечок
вже відправились в Україну,
і значна кількість з них, вже була
доставлена нашими водіями в Україні,
нашими волонтерами —
до ЗСУ, до підрозділів.
Через певний час почали
надходити інші запити
від наших військових,
від нашої територіальної оборони.
Це також вся Україна знає
ці запити: потрібні дрони,
потрібні рації,
потрібні сателітні телефони.
Тобто частина нашого бюджету,
майже від початку, пішла на те,
щоб забезпечити наших
хлопців засобами комунікації.
Дрони — один із найзатребуваніших
запитів від захисників України.
Про початок війни я почув відусюди,
всі мої друзі-американці слідкували
за розгортанням подій
на кордоні України і повірити в те,
що напад таки відбувся,
часу багато не зайняло.
До війни я більше займався
авіаційним сервісом
та експортував в Україну літаки
малої авіації, а тепер це лише дрони.
Я будую важкі дрони.
Скільки я себе памʼятаю,
я захоплений авіамоделізмом,
і останні 15 років — професійно.
На ньому базуються всі сучасні
безпілотні системи.
В мене є група друзів, фахівців
безпілотних авіасистем в НАСА,
які весь свій робочий день
бавляться з літачками за мільйони доларів.
І ми з ними схрещуємо літаки та квадрокоптери,
тобто розробляємо VITOL UIV —
це безпілотні літальні апарати з
вертикальним зльотом та посадкою.
Підтримка України з неба — це ще
один проєкт Олександра Тютюнника.
Це той випадок, коли публічна акція
переросла у конкретну допомогу бійцям.
Коли в березні по світу проходили
перші акції солідарності
під лозунгами
«Закрити небо над Україною»,
ми з друзями-авіаторами
влаштували прольоти величезного
прапора України над
Лос-Анжелісом і над Чикаго,
з написом «Close sky over Ukraine»
та «Pray for Ukraine».
Свою акцію ми назвали
«Підтримка з неба».
Тоді одне за одним почали
зʼявлятися відео про влучні удари з дронів,
і «Підтримка з неба»
органічно трансформувалася
в наступну стадію проєкту
«Підтримка з неба з дронів».
Для цих дронів ми також будуємо
станції наземного керування,
пишемо програмне забезпечення,
планування льотного завдання,
слідкуючи антени, камери
спостереження, тепловізори,
лазерні дальноміри з визначенням
координат цілі на землі.
Переваги від того — це,
уявіть собі байрактар, але вдвічі менший,
з розміром крил 3,5 метри,
і якому не потрібні смуга
або катапульта, який здатний
виконувати завдання до 100 км,
і бути більш як дві години у повітрі.
Тарас Винник часто використовував
дрон, знімаючи контент
для свого тревел-блогу.
До повномасштабної війни він
відвідав понад сорок країн
і заснував компанію Travel Bastards.
Ця компанія організовує
авторські тури різними країнами світу.
Під час однієї з моїх подорожей
мене й застала смс від дружини
про те, що: «Тарас, війна почалась».
Почали обговорювати,
чим ми можемо бути корисні,
чи ми повертаємося додому,
чи ми робимо щось в Європі.
Ніхто не знав,
чим можна займатись,
всі просили щось привезти з
Європи, тому власне в нас, мабуть,
одразу закралась думка, що можна
буде чимось допомагати з Європи.
Вирішили, шо будем займатись
бронежилетами.
Але дуже швидко зрозуміли, що
ми в цьому малокомпетентні хлопці.
Коли ми поїхали за
бронежилетами до Швейцарії,
ми купили перший пікап.
Це був Nissan Navara,
дуже хороша машина,
яка згодом поїхала на Харків.
Звідси, власне,
й почалась наша історія,
як ми почали переганяти
машини для Збройних Сил.
На сьогодні ми з нашими друзями
перегнали вже практично 100 автомобілів.
Сюди входять і пікапи,
і автомобілі швидкої допомоги,
і автомобілі для евакуації поранених.
Ми тепер не лише купуємо і
переганяємо автомобілі,
ми, як то кажуть,
робимо повний сервіс.
Після того,
як купуємо машину в Європі,
ми її переганяємо у Львів
до, власне, наших друзів.
Там її повністю підремонтовуємо:
міняємо масла, міняємо фільтри.
Я дуже затятий фанат
автомобілів з дитинства,
тому в мене немає поняття:
«Масло не будем міняти, з ним все окей».
Ці машини їдуть на війну,
а не пиріжки десь там
по Івано-Франківську возити,
тому ми всі тачки намагаємось
доводити до ідеалу,
наскільки це можливо.
Там же наші друзі
бронюють ці машини.
Броня витримує калібр 7.62.
Для мене, як для чайника,
це спочатку нічого не говорило,
але потім ми отримали класні
відгуки від військових,
кому ми передали машини з цією
бронею, і вони задоволені.
Інші друзі у Львові допомагають
на волонтерських засадах
ці машини малювати.
Більшість машин, які ми купуємо,
вони переважно в кумедних кольорах:
в якихось червоних,
помаранчевих, салатових.
Військові дуже тішаться,
коли їм одразу передають
машини в оливковому кольорі.
Авто, як і дрони — це розхідний
матеріал у захисників України.
Тому на війні в них
є постійна потреба.
Тарас із друзями продовжує
закуповувати автівки.
Деякі хлопці звітують,
яким ми передавали машини,
що за 2-3 дні тих машин уже немає.
Вони або, на жаль, підірвались,
або десь застрягли,
або перевернулись.
Звичайно, за сприятливих
обставин,
ця машина може їм
прослужити дуже довго,
а може за день її вже не стати,
і потрібно буде купувати ще одну.
Особисто моя мотивація —
то вона насправді дуже проста.
В мене є дочка, і я хочу,
щоб вона жила в Україні,
в Івано-Франківську,
щоб у неї не було
ніякої книжечки переселенця,
біженця, тимчасового прихистку.
Я не хочу, щоб вона була гостем в
чиїйсь країні,
навіть в дружніх до нас країнах.
Як-от в Польщі,
де до нас чудово ставляться і
дуже підтримують під час війни.
Але я хочу, щоб моя донька
прокидалась в себе вдома,
в своєму рідному місті.
Щоб наші діти росли в вільній
країні, в Україні,
і могли там виховувати своїх дітей,
а не постійно скитатись по закорднонах.
У Нідерландах трохи за шосту ранку.
Ще світає, а на одній із околиць
Амстердаму вже незвично людно.
Це зібралися волонтери,
які проводжають чергову колону
закуплених ними карет швидкої.
Автівки їдуть в Україну.
Моє життя було поставлене
на паузу з моменту початку війни в Україні.
Вероніка Муцей, співзасновниця
Фонду «Вітрила свободи».
Це нідерландська група допомоги Україні,
яку створили на десятий день
повномасштабної війни
Росії з Україною.
Ми закуповуємо медицину,
ми закупляємо машини швидкої допомоги,
ми завантажуємо їх
медичним обладнанням та медикаментами
і відправляємо їх у лікарні у Україну.
Це — Київ, це — Харків,
це — Миколаїв, це — Донбас,
це — Запоріжжя і Чернігів.
Чернігів доїхав сьогодні.
Так само ми відправили одну
машину пожежної допомоги,
яка поїде на Луганщину
справлятися з пожежами,
які відбуваються через розстріли
російською армією цивільних будинків.
І ми відправили 12 евакуаційних машин,
які займаються евакуацією людей
з фронтів, і відвозять
їх безпосередньо
до кареток швидкої допомоги.
[відповідає на запитання англійською]
— Я займаюсь.
Із березня волонтери фонду
«Вітрила свободи»
відправили більш 70 автівок.
Карети швидких волонтери фонду
шукають по всьому Євросоюзу.
Проводять техогляд, оформляють
необхідні для експорту документи.
Кожна така колона — це
сотні збережених життів українців.
Півтори тисячі кілометрів від
Нідерландів до Краковця
машини проїжджають за два дні.
Спочатку, коли були перші конвої,
в нас відправлялися 7 машин:
це 2 карети швидкої допомоги
і 5 машин підтримки.
Досить складно було знайти
водіїв, тому що ми розуміли,
що водії повинні перетнути кордон.
Тобто ти не знаходишся більше у
своїх комфортних Нідерландах.
Ти їдеш по території Євросоюзу,
і надалі останнім твоїм пунктом —
це перетнути кордон.
Ніхто не знав, яка буде ситуація.
Наразі більшість наших водіїв —
це саме нідерландці або люди з усього світу:
як Бразилія, як іспанці,
які просто хочуть допомагати.
Вони не можуть сидіти на місці,
вони розуміють ризики,
через які їм доводиться проходити
для того, щоб перетнути кордон.
[дівчина за кадром]:
— А ще в нас є француз!
[чоловік за кадром розчулюється]:
—Дякую. Забагато цукерок.
Коли ти бачиш результати
своєї роботи в Україні, коли ти бачиш,
що одна з машин,
яка була куплена абсолютно випадково,
і відправили ми її до Харкова
випадково,
я отримую дані про те,
що вона вже змогла евакуювати
більше ніж 250 осіб
з-під зруйнованих будівель,
і що найголовніше — осіб, які не
можуть пересуватися самостійно,
тобто вони мають якісь додаткові
потреби в пересуванні.
Це заставляє тебе працювати
ще сильніше.
[оплески]
Останнє, що я отримала,
це подяку від Залужного
стосовно роботи,
яку ми виконуємо, — це вже багато.
Після перемоги я хочу
повернутися до України,
побачити своїх батьків та друзів,
а також відбудовувати нашу країну.
Так, я планую
повернутись на Батьківщину.
Попрацювати над відновленням
нашого літака Антонов АН-225 «Мрія».
Я планую разом з іншими
волонтерами відбудовувати Україну.
Стати на коліна і подякувати нашим воїнам.
Оце я планую зробити.
Повернутись, щоб поприбирати
весь той срач, який залишають москалі.
Якщо я зупинюсь на якийсь час,
то я втрачу дуже багато цінного часу,
тому я зупинюсь пізніше.
Не зараз.
Для перемоги нам потрібно:
байрактари, джавеліни, N-Law-и.
Звичайно ж всіх нас надихає те,
що люди роблять в Україні.
Доки ми не виграємо —
переставати допомагати не можна.
Як архітектор в минулому,
я розумію велику необхідність,
в принципі, в усіх можливих силах
по відбудові нашої країни.
Може, це вже будуть
не каретки швидкої допомоги.
Я вже жартую, що це будуть якісь
будівельні крани та будівельні машини,
якими ми просто будемо їхати і
відбудовувати країну,
хоча б до мінімального стану,
як вона була перед війною.
Якщо ми обʼєднаємося,
всі будем робити хоча б щось,
ми переможемо, і це однозначно,
це всі розуміють.
Я тільки хочу,
щоб деякі українці,
які говорили, що ми — «братушкі»,
«браття», чи ще там якісь паскудні слова,
щоб в них багато чого змінилось.
Я вже це відчуваю, що в багатьох людей
переключився оцей такий клапан,
вони зрозуміли, хто є хто,
за що бореться Україна,
за що бореться «рускій мір».
На мою думку, суспільство тепер
буде глобальніше розуміти
і рухатися в найкращому напрямі
для України як самостійної держави,
а не як «меншого брата» Росії.
Зараз у нашого покоління є
можливість зафіксувати це
і передати наступним
поколінням так,
аби їм більше ніколи не хотілося
дружби з Росією.
«Борітеся — поборете»,
як казав класик.
Слава Україні, слава Збройним
Силам, і ми точно переможемо.
Все буде Україна.
Сьогодні ми зібралися всі разом з
дітьми і дорослими.
Такий марш пташок,
який буде казати про те,
що Україна переможе,
і нарешті пташки принесуть мир.
Ми всім серцем про це думаємо
і мріємо про це.
Війна, яка у мріях Путіна мала б
закінчитися захопленням Києва
на третій день вторгнення,
вже триває більш як п'ять місяців.
Україна гідно й гордо бореться
за європейські цінності,
демократію і свою незалежність.
І її в цій боротьбі підтримує
весь цивілізований світ.
Від урядів держав
до конкретних людей,
які приймають
українських переселенців у свій дім,
донатять для ЗСУ чи виходять
на мирні антивоєнні мітинги.
Величезна світова спільнота
підтримує нас
і вірить в нашу перемогу.
♪ [А ми тую червону калину підіймемо,] ♪
♪ [А ми нашу славну Україну,
гей, гей, розвеселимо!] ♪